it's a sensitive time in Hong Kong and
being seen at a protest could cost you
your job the focus of this small rally
was Cathay Pacific the airline is the
most high-profile case of what these
people believe is increasing
interference by China in Hong Kong
workplaces several Cathay Pacific
employees have been fired for making
social media posts in support of the
anti-government protests or for
attending rallies Cathay Pacific is a
publicly listed company but one of its
major shareholders is Air China which is
owned by the Chinese government's some
staff have resigned from the company and
protests like politician and pilot
jeremy tam this kind of you know
interference from the Beijing government
it just changes completely and everybody
you fear of you know being put under the
spotlight it's not just Cathay Pacific
that's coming under pressure from
Beijing there's a wider atmosphere
creeping into the Hong Kong corporate
world that if you want to continue doing
business with China
then you should distance yourself and
your staff from the protests last week
it was the turn of accountants to take
to the streets to reject interference
from Beijing staff from major firms like
KPMG and Deloitte had earlier taken out
a newspaper ad criticizing their
companies for ignoring Hong Kong people
and the reasons for the protests after
pressure from Beijing the companies
released statements distancing
themselves from the ads Cathay Pacific
declined
al-jazeera's request for an interview
but the reason given for the action
against staff is security Chinese
aviation authorities say they won't
allow Cathay flights to enter their
airspace if they are operated by anyone
who has participated in or supported
protests affect that Cathy's aircraft do
need to fly into China
space than China's entitled to ask them
to live by their rules as well far as we
are concerned we totally support the
freedom of opinion freedom of opinion
continues to be expressed on the streets
but in the workplace it's becoming
increasingly difficult Wayne hey al
Jazeera Hong Kong